the titans believed corey davis would be
a legitimate player when they made him
somewhat of a surprise top 10 pick a
couple of years ago he now says as he
enters his third season he's hoping the
game will slow down when we talked about
this earlier chris you had a strong
reaction now what's your thought when
you hear a guy like corey davis say he
hopes the game slows down you know i i
you know and this is my thought first of
all i know these are young guys but
again the the the
you're a top 10 pick you're a top five
pick the my reaction to that is
we shouldn't be talking about this going
into year three if you're a top five
pick and i don't know if you're worthy
of a top five pick if in fact we're
still talking about the game needing to
slow down for you uh going into year
three i think he almost justifies that
notion right there and that fact with
that statement to me where you know
again yeah i mean it's just a little
troubling to me especially at the wide
receiver position i think it's more more
that you hear about this at quarterback
than you would hear about this wide
receiver again wide receivers about
going out running the route you heard in
the huddle and then run that route to
your best capabilities and get open and
and go snatch the ball out of the air
and you know you we never heard guys
like odell beckham jr or mike evans or
deandre hopkins make comments about ooh
the game needs to slow down you know why
because they were so physically gifted
that the first practice they were on the
field the game was slowed down and they
were like damn this is the nfl i'm the
man here just like i was in college
nothing's changed okay awesome so that
to me just scares me not to say he can't
be awesome this year or whatever it is
but when i hear things like that uh yeah
i just go oh i don't know if that guy's
worth the top five pick if we're still
talking about that here in year three
and regardless of whether the game slows
down or even needs to slow down at this
point for corey davis there is kind of a
rule of thumb for our first round
receiver that if it hasn't happened by
the third year it's never going to
happen so this is the year to make it
work yes it's it's it's up or out time
for corey davis and slows down doesn't
slow down speeds up doesn't speed up
bottom line is if you don't produce now
chances are you're never going to yeah
no and again you know i'm not i mean i
don't know this but i look at context
clues they can't be that happy i mean
they needed help but the receiver
position regardless but you know they
signed adam humphries in free agency and
then go out and draft an aj brown in the
second round out of ole miss who a lot
of guys thought was maybe a first round
talent i think that there too tells you
that you know they're not necessarily
excited about their number one target on
the team
they're gonna have to make that fifth
year option decision by next may there's
no way they're picking that up they're
looking at about 16 17 million dollars
out right now and salary because it was
a top 10 pick yeah and it's so he'll be
in a contract here next year so if your
three doesn't work out year four you'll
have every reason to come out and have a
big season because year four is the
opportunity to show what you can do and
get paid it's almost like a cordero
patterson situation where maybe at this
point he should just try to focus on if
it doesn't work this year developing
other skills like patterson did to his
credit yeah it never really worked for
him as a downfield receiver he found
other things he could do and he's
crafted a nice little career for himself
if it doesn't work this year for corey
davis chris maybe that's what he needs
to consider yeah you got to do anything
you can to get on the field stay
relevant show the the show hey the more
you can do right that teams love to hear
that the more you can do if you can do
more than one thing on a roster and fill
holes and and bring different things to
game planning on a weekly basis you
certainly increase your wealth and yes
cordell patterson is a perfect example
of that hey that's been my entire goal
throughout this 20 years or so i've been
in this business do as much as you can
now i don't do much of it very well but
the more you do the greater the chance
that you can kind of hang around a
little bit longer than maybe otherwise
what all right we've hung around long
enough for this thursday chris enjoy
your your weekend your normal weekend i
mean most people celebrate a three-day
weekend i if you have a three-day
weekend every weekend what's there to
celebrate so i find ways to do it i'll
tell you i find ways to celebrate it
regardless yeah i i can imagine what
that involves you got a four-day weekend
coming up in a few weeks oh which makes
i guess it's special because of memorial
day oh great great that's right now on
now on are you like the typical person
with the four-day work week that when
there is a holiday that lands during the
week you still work the other four days
or is it a three-day week for you oh uh
no i i mean this time of the year
there's no games going on anytime i can
squeeze three days of work into a week
i'd rather just do the three days yes i
thought that was going to go a different
way yes i thought you did yeah i bet you
thank you thank you for helping me get
through the slow times while we come up
upon our hiatus that we'll be here
before you know it end of june we go off
for a month but uh you know it's a
challenge it's it's a lot harder i know
we got to go but it's a lot harder this
time of year to come up with content
rest of the year it's fallen out of the
trees it really takes planning and
thought and creativity to fill up three
hours and the extra 20 minutes that we
do yeah it does but we i feel like this
week especially i mean we've had a lot
of fun on the show all week so somehow
somewhere you me stats matt casey we
found enough crap to talk about and have
fun with and uh i i've enjoyed coming to
work every day this week well we'll find
a lot of crap to talk about tomorrow
even though chris won't be here to talk
about it everybody have a great thursday
chris great work as always we'll see you
tomorrow with another edition pfd live
big cat will be in the building
p-f-t-o-t chris sims on button coming up
later today and check us out all day
long at profootballtalk.com everybody
have a great day see ya
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports